im hessischen limburg stehen dieser
obskuren stahl objekte in der
fußgängerzone herum bei den rostigen
riesen handelt es sich um drei info
stelen die sollen bürger und touristen
eigentlich mit informationen über
gastronomie sehenswürdigkeiten und
ähnlichem versorgen dafür hat die stadt
stolze 350.000 euro in die hand genommen
doch kaum jemand nutzt die infosäulen
außerdem funktionieren sie nicht richtig
das ist leider eine große
geldverschwendung die wir hier in der
stadt haben wenn die dinger links
funktionieren würden es ist für mich
unerträglich dass in einer limburger
altstadt mit blick auf den dom so ein
scheußliches verrostetes teil steht
ich finde es auch unsinnig weil guckt
sowieso keiner drauf denn die säuren
einzelanfertigungen laufen nicht
vernünftig marien roth regt sich seit
langem über die dinger auf ein kleiner
praxistest funktioniert also zuerst aber
auch nach ewig langen herumgedrückt
passiert nichts
der computer hat eigene dienstzeiten ein
paar hundert meter weiter klappt auch
nix dem computer scheint es zu kalt zu
sein
er tut es heute gar nicht im sommer wird
es dann zu heiß deshalb müssen die
säulen von innen gekühlt werden
wartungskosten im jahr knapp 14.000 euro
zufällig treffen wir einen stadtrat der
damals für die anschaffung gestimmt hat
er trägt es mit galgenhumor ja im
vorfeld wollen die hand gehoben
aber ich wusste dass es soweit hätten
das gewusst hätten dass sich natürlich
gesagt macht es nicht im limburger
rathaus scheint man mittlerweile den
spaß an den teuren stehlen verloren zu
haben vor der kamera will sich niemand
äußern schriftlich heißt es unstrittig
ist dass kosten und nutzen in einem
schlechten verhältnis zueinander stehen
die stadt sucht auch nach lösungen einer
weiteren verwendung völlig verwendung
frei ist diese info säule die stadt hat
sie zugeklebt die limburger sind bedient
kosten die man anderweitig einsetzen
kann diese kostenrechnung die würde ich
tatsächlich gerne mal neugieriger weise
sehen
um tatsächlich mal zu wissen wie kommt
er so ein batzen geld zusammen sondern
weil ich als privatmann wenn ich mir
sowas da reinstellen und habe noch
jährlich 14.000 folgekosten nur für die
kühlung und das funktioniert nicht da
geht es auch gerade wieder abreisen
einfach abreißen kommt aber nicht
infrage
dann müsste die stadt 58.000 euro
förderung ans land zurückzahlen
deshalb stehen die dinge weiter in der
gegend rum und rosten gemütlich vor sich
hin